merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
Présidente Cécile
cuckerman le 7 octobre vous l'avez
rappelé une attaque terroriste sans
précédent a touché Israël nous l'avons
condamné fermement à plusieurs repris
encore avec vous la semaine dernière au
cours de cette attaque 24 de nos
compatriotes ont perdu la vie se sont
encore disparus et plusieurs sont
probablement retenus en otage à Gaza
face à l'horreur nous l'avons dit Israël
a le droit à la sécurité Israël a le
droit de se défendre dans le respect du
droit international
humanitaire comme l'a affirmé le
président de la République rien ne
justifie jamais que des cibiles soient
pris pour cible aussi à mon tour
permettez-moi de dire mon effroi face à
la frappe qui a touché l'hôpital àarli
de Gaza causant de nombreuses victimes
palestiniennes je veux avoir une pensée
pour les familles et les proches des
victimes cela ne fait aucun doute chaque
vie
compte les hôpitaux et le personnel
médical sont protégés par le droit
international humanitaire il doit
s'appliquer en toutes
circonstances dès hier le président de
la République a condamné très fermement
cette attaque toute la lumière devra
être faite sur ce drame
les auteurs devront être identifiés et
rendre des comptes madame la Présidente
cuckerman dans ce contexte dramatique la
position de la France est très claire
d'abord nous sommes au côté de nos
compatriotes je tiens à saluer le
travail de nos diplomates mobilisés
jours et nuits d'ici ce soir nous aurons
permis à 3500 de nos concitoyens de
rejoindre la
France la France demande la libération
de tous les états de tous les a
sans délis sans conditions la ministre
des Affaires étrangères Catherine Colona
a rencontré les familles dimanche à tel
avive et comme l'a dit le président de
la République hier nous travaillons
activement à leur
libération plusieurs dizaines de nos
concitoyens sont par ailleurs bloqués à
Gaza dans une situation extrêmement
précaire nous les suivons
individuellement et faisons notre
maximum pour leur permettre de quitter
Gaza
ensuite je l'affirme à nouveau les
populations palestiniennes ne sont pas
responsables de la
situation nous avons annoncé un soutien
supplémentaire de la France de 10
millions d'euros pour l'aide humanitaire
à Gaza nous appelons à un accès
humanitaire immédiat à Gaza afin que
l'aide des Nations Unies puisse être
acheminée et parvienne aux populations
palestinienne c'est une urgence des
milliers de vies en
dépand enfin sur le plan diplomatique
nous multiplions les contacts avec les
pays de la région pour éviter l'escalade
et un embrasement
régional notre position est constante
une issue politique avec deux états
vivants en paix et en sécurité c'est le
seul horizon pour la paix aux Nations
unies la France soutiendra cet
après-midi le projet de résolution
présenté par le Brésil qui condamne sans
ambigué l'attaque terroriste tout en
rappelant la nécessité de permettre
l'accès de l'aide humanitaire et la
protection de la population civile de
Gaza madame la Présidente
cuckerman la France cherchera toujours
le chemin de la paix elle sera toujours
un artisan de la sécurité et de la
stabilité au Proche Orient elle sera
toujours du côté du droit international
c'est le sens de notre mobilisation et
elle continuera et je vous confirme
madame la Présidente que le parle a
l'occasion de débattre de la situation
au Proche Orient dès la semaine
prochaine je vous
remercie